[Music]
I I was just thinking backstage that the
perfect way to start this show would be
uh be to sing Montel Jordan's uh This is
how we do it but I don't know if you
know much about TV that would cost us
like 50
$50,000 if I if I sang that song it
would be great to I want
to you can you can do it there's
no
this is
free okay I'll
stop welcome everybody Welcome to the
Pete home show I'm so excited you're
here and if you're watching on the iPad
in your bathroom thanks for the extra
mile dedication I really appreciate that
can I just get something off my chest
right up top here is uh I'm not a strip
I'm not a strip club not a I'm not a
strip club kind of fella I don't know if
you can tell just by looking at me I'm
just kind of more like a those amusement
parks that are Christmas year round
that's more my
vibe you know what I mean don't get me
long wrong my goal in life is to see
naked women um I meant legally yeah
legally not like oh yeah
juicy juice juicy that's disgusting but
I don't like strip clubs I just want I
just want to let you know you're not
alone if you're a guy straight guy
doesn't like strip clubs you're fine
you're not alone I'm right there I never
know how to act at a strip club I really
Envy guys that can go and just own it
you know what I mean plop right down in
the front row and just be like yeah I'm
garbage this is what I'm about and I
don't care who knows make with the sweet
tits I
need meanwhile I'm just sitting there
just
like I never know where to
look you know what's underrated lap cot
you're laughing and learning like
that I've been I've been before I've
been I got a lap dance uh once one time
um at not at
Epcot oh Cinderella you skank you're a
lady and a [__] it wasn't it's a decent
Disneyland skank riff but it didn't do
too well I got a laps one time and uh
the stripper this is a true story she
bent over uh this is what they do
apparently she bent over in my face and
uh I felt it warranted some sort of
reaction but I didn't know what to do
this is true I didn't know what to do
there was an ass in my face and I just
went
fantastic directly into her butt like
her butt
muffled the word fantastic it didn't
bounce it was
absorbed like it's in there now like in
a few decades she's going to get a
colonoscopy the doctor's going to be
like uh Mercedes
did someone say fantastic into your butt
about 30 years
[Applause]
[Music]
ago